Uh tá gravando é o hack E aí galera que
assiste meu canal tudo bom com vocês boa
noite
tava com saudade de mim tava [__]
nenhuma Você nem liga mais para mim
antes eu era um rei hoje eu sou um Del
Rey eu gostava quando você entrava
dança mas tatus bonezinho do Hype se
você quiser o boné do Hype para ser
raipado primeiro link da descrição do
vídeo Meu Deus O cara já volta fazendo
propaganda Mas minhas propagandas agora
estão se adaptando junta as propagandas
do mercado é cinco segundos rápido igual
do YouTube para você parar de assistir
10.000 vezes os mesmos shows agora tá
entrando no Show novo dia 19 de
Fevereiro de 2023 domingo às 10:00 da
manhã só na Netflix Isso não é um cu tá
vendo é rápido olha como é que fica o
negócio na minha cabeça
grande do [__] Ô vou começar
respondendo uma pergunta que vocês
sempre fazem para mim William isso
porque que você não faz vídeo novo é
porque eu não aguento ficar falando das
mesmas coisas direto carnaval sabe o que
acontece as mesmas coisas aí eu vou lá
gravar e posta aí você de novo dia das
mães que nossa São João de novo mas
agora aconteceu uma coisa nova no
planeta inteiro um assunto do planeta aí
eu falei ah agora sim óvnis tem aí é
novo meu menino bonitinho do papai que
hoje eu tô gravando isso e esse vídeo
vai para o YouTube Tá bom então pode dar
um gritinho aqui que a gente vai lá ah
eu fiz um vlogzinho eu vou ficar mixando
entra aqui lá entendeu quando eu vou
contar piada lá bota para cá para vocês
irem para vocês ah engraçado entendeu eu
falei no Twitter um dia desse tava tá
muito quieto 95
[Música]
todo seu povo filmando Marco uma
batedeira às vezes um liquidificador mas
filmado relato e tal aí Donato parou de
aparecer as coisas eu falei bicho tá
muito quieto Os caras estão muito tá
dentro tá errado aí meus amigos
paranoico com isso dele de novo e essas
pessoas que são paranoica com o negócio
de tempo negócio de universo eu tenho um
amigo que é muito doido sempre foi assim
aí quando parou ele ficou na dele pra
ele não ficar pagando de maluco ele foi
lá dele ficou quietinho e agora voltou
ele ficou doido de novo ele começou
falar comigo eu já vi Cara eu já vi um
ET só que esse meu amigo Ele mente muito
então não dá para Acreditar nele porque
eu já ouvi história dele ele contando
que ele já contou a história tão absurda
para mim que na história ele morre
mas tu não tá aqui me contando a
história desgraça Moço mas depois eu
vivi agora eu fico pensando que se
realmente tiver uma vida extraterrestre
e eles for Verde cabeçudo todas as
pessoas que falaram que viram as pessoas
que pensaram para fazer os filme tão
certo para todo mundo certo é o que eu
gosto de dizer o povo não inventa só
aumenta eu então às vezes a cabeça não é
tão grande assim é só sei lá meio de
cearensezinho aí piada com cearense e
cabeça
repetitiva antigo por isso que a gente
tem que sair passear atualizar mas ruim
você não dá credibilidade porque você
acabou de dizer que você tinha a cabeça
grande por causa do boné
piauiense meu filho tá vendo direito
piauiense pode ter a cabeça grande
a galera já tá achando a Fabi vou falar
que você não entende mas minhas piadas
mas eu vou contar minhas piadas e você
preconceituoso comigo eu tenho certeza
que vocês não vão mais entender pode
contar alguma coisa
sabe qual é a pior parte
tá vendo não tem empatia
nem esperou eu contar pra vocês como
vocês só estão sendo preconceituoso
mesmo sabe qual é a pior parte é porque
hoje tudo é piques então se você para no
sinal aí vem a pessoa que precisa do
dinheiro e você não tem dinheiro porque
é tudo com pizza e a pessoa pedindo e
você dentro da Posse quando você não tem
o dinheiro você procura em lugares que
nunca teve
que é guerra e tal mas eu acho que eles
item e que eles sempre observa porque é
assim que a gente estuda as outras
coisas não tem como quando tu vai
estudar o leão Tu entra lá mas o leão
dorme mais ele é Ô Daniel na cova dos
leões a gente veio de longe atrás do
mato cobre com folha também tira foto
morre um a gente vai correndo pega um
pedaço faz uma um um negócio e assim que
explodir eu acho que eles ficam
estudando a gente não vem porque eles
ficam esperando a gente evoluir um
pouquinho e a vida inteligente porque
não tem como não ser inteligente
inteligente para vir até aqui observar
mas burro para escolher um lugar porque
Escolhe os Estados Unidos nas potência
dá tempo de você falar ai pá derruba
deu tempo não Discovery channe gravar do
planeta x-97 viemos aí bala meu filho lá
no planeta dele gente deu certo não
vamos estabelecer em contato no Canadá
fumo o goleiro lugar errado por que que
não foram na Coreia do Norte ah Coreia
do Norte tem bomba atômica é só ir não
tem energia piada que eu não posso mais
fazer turismo na Coreia do Norte que
eles vê isso aqui vasculha aí ó escolher
um lugar certo mandar pro Piauí Piauí
tentaram recapturar uma onça mataram a
porta basta um tranquilizante deram bem
75 se foi a pobrenagem para ela
maior feliz do brasileiro
tivesse aparecido na minha cidade Bom
Jesus minha mãe recebia fazia almoço
apresentava a casa minha mãe gosta de
mostrar as porras que ninguém quer saber
nós vamos derrubar essa parede aqui
fazer uma caixa d'água hahaha ninguém
quer saber mas ela adora minha mãe
constrói coisa toda hora cada da minha
mãe é um labirinto tem que roubar não
que você se perde lá dentro tem três
portão na mesma rua que dá para a mesma
capa que é isso chegou ela construiu em
outro banheiro de novo eu falo mãe deixa
eu meter ele um trator nessa casa
todinho chama o arquiteto eu faço a casa
mais lindo do Castelo para a senhora
mora que você merece morar num castelo
Ela já começa a zangar e falar assim
porque mãe nordestina quando ela se
zangada Elas começam a falar fino para
dar atenção no que ela quer dizer não
vai de jeito nenhum deixa bem gente que
tá que desse jeito tá muito bom porque
que eles não estabelecem o contato não
vem antes aí esperando nós desenvolver
gente eles viu que a gente estava
fazendo os nossos próprios experimentos
e resolveram esperas quando estava para
invadir Olha o BBB para para aí espera
aí
eles estão fazendo experimento entre
eles estão pegando vários humanos
botando dentro de uma casa eles ficam
assistindo de casa eles fazendo coisa em
casa filmandos
como assim É estresse isolamento Qual é
o limite do ser humano ou quem está
atuando que não está atuando quem está
jogando que não está jogando isso é
incrível hein vamos esperar acontecer
outro amigo mas eles já fizeram 23 vezes
não Mas de repente alguma coisa
diferente pode acontecer nesse esperar
quando vieram de novo para para outro
que foi rapaz vamos lá e disse não calma
eles estão fazendo aquilo aí eu até
tenho não é que esse agora tem boi e
vaca galinha
Esse é interessante que as pessoas têm
que mexer com bosta e com coisa em
galinha
ele demora e não vem é esperando a gente
desenvolver entendeu Eu acho que ele não
vê que ele deve achar engraçado as
coisas que a gente pensa assim tipo olha
Eles olham para o céu e eles falam que
os astros são os bichinhos dele olha
escorpião
ou então é mais impressão mesmo sei lá
às vezes pegaram uma pessoa pra pesquisa
eles pegaram uma pessoa errada entendeu
tem gente que não sabe conversar chega
lá e fala pesquisa
para o cara Como é o seu estilo de vida
dele cara
é que eu sou de libra né o cara [__] que
pariu bota para lá de novo então uma
mensagem aqui para casa alguma
Alienígena esteja observando se não
tiver também enviar uma mensagem aí eles
vão mais cara brasilmen Brasil negócio é
Brasil aqui nós fala de tudo qualquer
coisa eu acho que nós tem muita sorte o
brasileiro tem muita sorte é porque se
os alienígenas souber que aqui no Brasil
um monte de 12 invadiu o Congresso
Nacional
Não vamos deixar Os Comunistas
transformar em nossos fios em LGBT carne
nas mesas
Então é isso se você não é um alienígena
já clica em gostei
dia 19 agora domingo tem um novo show
para vocês assistirem no Netflix se
chama isso não é um culto tá bom Espero
que vocês assistam e eu quero que você
comente aqui embaixo isso fala sobre
esse tema aqui fala uma coisa aleatória
para eu ir atrás de
tentar fazer que vai falar as mesmas
coisas sinal de Fevereiro Isso não é um
culto na Netflix e em março aqui no
canal um filmezinho que eu fiz só para
vocês e é de grátis hein espero que
vocês gostem muito junto é nós
tamo junto pode vir para cá
[Aplausos]